Hey, everyone.  Previously we looked at what price elasticity is a quick way to calculate it, and we saw how to interpret it with a demand curve.
What we didn't do is explore what type of demand curve we were using or what type of optimal pricing we should be considering.
Let's now take a look at that.
Let's start with demand.
We have two types we want to deal with here, individual and aggregate.
We covered this a bit earlier in the course, but it's good to come back to it.
Let's say you have subscribed to streaming services and are considering a third.
The first two, Netflix and Spotify, cost $15 and $10 per month.
You are considering adding Hulu, but its price is at $10 per month, so that's an extra $10 that you have to weigh in.
You're not sure if the marginal benefit is worth the marginal cost.
This type of information helps us understand individual demand curves because an individual prices at different prices, an individual ch consume how much they want.
For example, if your current Netflix subscription goes to $20, you may decide that the benefit no longer justifies the cost, so your quantity demand falls to zero.
For Hulu, it may be that the price needs to be lowered down to $5 for you to enter the market.
Thus your quantity demand rises with the decrease in price.
Now, the now we can take this information and expand it horizontally across all consumers.
Let's assume that there are two consumers inside this market.
We have individual one here, and we just previously saw this.
At price of $15, they want 1 of Netflix per month.
At a price of 20, they want none.
Now we're gonna bring in consumer number two.
And we see that at a price of 20, they consume one month of Netflix, but at a price of 15, they consume two months of Netflix.
Now what we want to do is look at these individual prices and how many months that they want to consume at those individual prices and horizontally sum across both individuals.
And this gives us our aggregate demand.
So our aggregate demand here at a price of $20, we see that only one month is consumed, and that comes from individual two.
But at a price of $15, we see that three months are consumed, and that comes from the two months that two consumes at $15 and the one month that individual one consumes at $15.
So that's how we determine how aggregate demand comes in.
Now, the individual will have a lot of determinants that will affect their elasticity.
So let's look at each of these.
The first is going to be substitutability the more substitutes you have, the higher your elasticity.
We're talking about streaming services.
So let's look at all the different streaming services or a lot of the streaming services that exist.
So as I have more options available to me, my elasticity of demand for streaming services is going to increase.
If I only had one, then I would have either no demand or have highly inelastic demand.
Our next one is the broadness of definition of the market that we're considering.
The elasticity is higher for more narrowly defined goods.
Consider the Tesla Model S being compared to all electric vehicles.
If we bundle all electric vehicles into the market basket, then we would say it has more inelastic demand.
But if we look at just one particular car that narrows down that particular good, then we're going to have more elastic demand.
Then the amount spent on the good goods that consume more of your budget have a higher elasticity.
Let's look at this example here.
Buying a smartphone versus a smartphone case.
Smartphone case may cost you $5 to $10 off of Amazon, but a smartphone can range anywhere from 500 to $1500, depending on what kind of model that you get.
So it's going to have a higher elasticity.
And then time horizons goods become more price elastic with a longer time horizon.
In this case, think about gasoline.
As gasoline prices increase over time, people adjust to those price increases and they become more price sensitive or more price elastic price elastic towards those increased prices.
But keep in mind, these are for the individual.
As we begin to aggregate these across all individuals to get to this aggregate demand curve that we're so curious about, we're going to see that the elastic consumers and the inelastic consumers are going to cancel each other out a little bit.
And what we can say is that an increase in price will cause quantity to fall, but not as much because some people have inelastic demand and others have elastic demand.
So let's move on to our next problem.
Where do we set price?
Let's consider a single subscription to keep the analysis very simple.
Here, we're going to assume that a Netflix subscription costs $15 a month.
And we have 1 million subscribers per month.
This gives us a total revenue of $15,000,000.
Now let's raise the price to $18 a month.
And you can see that we lose 200,000 subscribers.
Now the 800,000 times the $18 per month gives us a total revenue of 14,000,000.4 or $14,400,000.
Okay, so we do lose revenue.
In this case, we also lose some subscribers.
Now what Happens if we lowered the price to $12.
We gain 200,000 new subscribers.
But notice what happens to our total revenue.
Total revenues back down again to $14,400,000.
So we can say that if we're looking to maximize our total revenue, then we want to set the price at $15.
But something that I want you to think about here is looking at increasing the price and decreasing the price.
Notice that our revenue falls in both cases.
Now, what does this mean in terms of elasticity?
Well, we're going to get there, but we have to do so by thinking at the margin, finding the right price at the margin.
So we know that when we equate our marginal revenue and our marginal cost, what we end up finding is the profit maximizing quantity and the profit maximizing price.
So that is what we're trying to do.
Now, here's a little bit of math behind the scenes.
You don't need to know how we got there.
Just look at this formula because it relates marginal revenue, price and elasticity all together.
Things that we have been talking about this entire time.
Now, anytime that we have a price, or, excuse me, elasticity that's greater than 1, we have elastic demand and our marginal revenue is going to be positive.
So notice what we've done here.
I have a price of $10.
My elasticity of demand.
Don't take the absolute value here because otherwise the formula does not work.
So I have a price elasticity of minus 4.
So 1 plus 1 over minus 4 is this 1 minus 0.25, which is 0.75.
0.75 times 10 gives me the 750.
So whenever I have a price elasticity that is greater than one, I'm going to have positive marginal revenue.
If I had a price elasticity equal to 1, then this would be 0.
What happens if my elasticity is less than 1?
Well, in this case, we've set it down to inelastic demand minus 0.25.
And this is saying one plus one over minus 0.25.
And that is going to give us.
That's going to give us four.
So one minus four is minus three.
Minus three times 10 is minus 30.
So what we see here is that whenever we have marginal revenue, excuse me, price elasticity less than 1, our marginal revenue is going to be negative.
That's not where we want to be.
We want to be where our marginal revenue is at least going to be positive.
So here we want to say that firms will operate in the elastic region of their demand curve.
Otherwise, we'll be Losing money from any additional sales, that is, if you're in the inelastic region of your demand curve.
Now, again, we know that marginal revenue equals marginal cost finds us our profit maximizing price and quantity.
And so all we have to do is go into this first equation and put marginal cost there instead of marginal revenue, and this is what we get.
Now, I'm going to rearrange this a little bit to put price on the other side.
So now we have this equation, and the reason why we're doing this is because we're trying to find the optimal price.
Because firms can know what their marginal cost is, but they might not know what their optimal price is.
So here we know what our marginal cost is, and we can get two conclusions out of this.
One, if the elasticity of demand is greater than 1, then price is pretty close to the marginal cost.
And two, if elasticity is less than marginal, one, less than one, then the firm has a higher markup over marginal cost.
Now, another way to say this.
The less elastic your demand is, the more pricing power you have, because consumers are less sensitive to price changes.
On the other hand, the more elastic your demand is, the closer price has to be to marginal cost, because consumers are less sensitive to price changes.
Let's look at two examples to clarify this a little bit.
So we're going to set our marginal cost equal to $10, our elasticities to minus 2 and minus 0.5.
So we have elastic demand and we have inelastic demand.
Bring back in our equation that we're trying to satisfy here, and we're going to plug in our values.
Marginal cost is $10 over 1 plus 1 half.
And that's going to make that a minus 1 half.
So $10 over 1 minus 1 half, which is 10 over 0.5, and that's how we get the price of $20.
Okay, now let's do our next one.
And we have 10 over 1 plus 1 over minus 0.5.
So that's the same as saying 10 over 1 minus 2, which is 10 over minus 1.
And that's how we get a negative price.
Now, if you get that negative price, that's kind of a nonsense answer because you don't set negative prices.
So we can't have that negative price.
This implies our marginal revenue is also going to be negative.
So again, this doesn't make sense because we're attempting to maximize our price, our profit, and we need our marginal revenue equal to our marginal cost.
Now, let's go back to our marginal revenue formula here, and let's Plug in that price of $20 that we found with the elastic demand and the elasticity of minus 2.
And what we're going to find is that our marginal revenue is equal to $10.
In this case, we find that our marginal revenue equals our marginal cost.
So this tells us that $20 is the profit maximizing price.
All right?  So anytime we're looking at trying to figure this out, we need to keep in mind pricing isn't just about picking a number that feels right.  Okay?
It's understanding how the customers are going to behave whenever we do change prices.
Are they sensitive to price changes?
Are they not sensitive to price changes?
Can they.
Can we find what their willingness to pay is based off these price changes?
Based off these elasticities?
All right, so here again, let's just reiterate this kind of stuff here.
We start with demand.
We look at how consumers behave with demand.
We've already covered demand.
Then we look at the elasticity.
We calculate our elasticities out.
That tells us how sensitive our consumers are going to be to price changes.
Then the elasticity through this equation shapes what the marginal revenue is going to be.
How much more, more extra money are we going to be making from selling that one extra unit?
All right, but again, we don't price just earn revenue or pricing to make a profit.
That's why we compare the marginal revenue to the marginal cost.
That's the cost producing one more unit.
Once we find where marginal revenue, marginal revenue equals marginal cost, then we know we found the sweet spot because that's where we maximize profit.
In our next video, we're going to take a look at how to calculate the elasticity of demand, followed by more analysis of elasticity and total revenue.  That's it.
Hope you've enjoyed it.